No one has ever come back from 3 - 1.
Agonizing defeat.
Down 5 - 1.
We've all been underestimated and counted out.
In those moments, we felt like it was over.
But it's when we were given no chance,...
...that we somehow found that last bit of strength to keep fighting.
And then we did what no one thought we could,...
...not even ourselves.
We came back from the impossible,...
...from being broken.
We found a way when it seemed hopeless.
We came back when we should have been long forgotten,...
...but we did it time and time again.
Right now, we're fighting for something...
...much bigger than a win or championship,...
...but if we learned anything from sports,...
...is that no matter how far down we may be,...
...we are never far too down to come back.